[Musica]
bello che è partito prima l'applauso
prima che io entrassi e adesso quando
entri hai la sede Ecco adesso non vedo
nessuno Grazie buongiorno
buongiorno buonasera
Allora prima di iniziare devo dire due
cose la prima è che come avete visto
anche da
aminatà Gabriella l'ho detto bene ok lei
ha usato delle slide chi ha parlato chi
parlerà dopo di me utilizzerà delle
slide meravigliose Io di solito sto alle
slide Cioè ne capisco più di pettini che
di slide
però ho dovuto farle mi perdonerete per
la qualità delle Slime ma tanto è la
prospettiva quella che conta e siamo con
questa e questa è la prima cosa che vi
chiedo la seconda ho visto il pubblico
in sala
e si parla di gioventù vedo un sacco di
giovani Ecco il mio intervento
si riferisce ai giovani soprattutto ai
giovani che hanno una ventina d'anni di
esperienza oltre i 30
e capirete tra poco perché
Elisa ha parlato del titolo di questo
mio intervento che si chiama Prima il
piacere poi il dovere
e dire in Veneto
Prima il piacere poi il dovere
devi considerare proprio una prospettiva
molto ampia no e io nasco Naturalmente
con il vecchio con il proverbio che con
cui tutti quanti siamo nati prima il
dovere poi il piacere mia madre
mi ha cresciuto con Prima il dovere per
piacere fin da quando allattava prima
finisci poi eventualmente giochi vai
alle elementari prima finisci i compiti
Prima fai il tuo dovere e poi
eventualmente vai a giocare Vai con gli
amici e poi così alle medie nei miei
otto anni di liceo
capite bene che
c'è speranza per tutti
e quindi questo questo questo messaggio
no del primo dovere per piacere prima di
avere per piacere tu da quando sei
bambino lo senti e non lo metti mai in
discussione perché funziona così tutto
il mondo funziona così da sempre vorrei
iniziare parlando di una io faccio
questo lavoro da avevo 23 anni quando ho
iniziato quindi sono 27 anni che faccio
il coach
e mi è capitato di lavorare con diverse
persone prima vi dicevo mi riferisco
alle persone che sono dei giovani
trentenni con Vent'anni di esperienza
perché bene o male il cliente tipo che
si rivolge a me per il tipo di coaching
che io faccio a dai 40 anni in su e
magari ha iniziato a lavorare a
vent'anni a 25 anni a 25 anni hai la
fame vuoi ottenere risultati per te non
esiste altro Se poi hai la smania di
diventare qualcuno di avere successo di
ottenere risultati di costruirti un
futuro Tu vivi non dico 24 ore su 24 ma
3/4 della tua giornata con questa
ossessione positiva in testa e non è un
problema Ti piace il tuo lavoro e
soprattutto hai questo hai radicato
questa convinzione che diventa
un'identità Prima il dovere per piacere
Prima il dovere per piacere
e un giorno mi si presenta a casa mi ha
richiesto consulenza Diego e vorrei che
immaginasse Diego
parlo di Diego ma potrei parlarvi di
Stefano di Marzia di Lucia di Paolo di
diverse persone che vivono esattamente
come Diego mi si presenta a casa con tre
telefoni me li lancia sul tavolo e mi
dice
Io ho 57 anni da quando ho 25 anni esco
il lunedì mattina alle 7 da casa rientro
alla sera alle 7:30
per anni è andata bene così fin quando
ero da solo
e per me non è mai stato un problema io
ho uno spirito di sacrificio molto forte
all'inizio andava tutto bene mi prendevo
i miei spazi mi prendevo i tempi Diego
un appassionato di arti marziali un
appassionato di sport e quindi nella
pausa pranzo o alla sera quando tornava
dal lavoro riusciva a dedicarsi a il suo
piacere
ad un certo punto necessariamente
giustamente Diego decide di mettere su
famiglia e quindi ha una moglie ha dei
figli e continua a fare la stessa vita
nello stesso modo perché non sa fare
altro non sa fare altro in nessun altro
modo
È solo che non hai più livello di
energia che avevi quando avevi 25 anni
le priorità sono cambiate
Ma non ti sei accorto di una cosa
che quello che prima era un momento di
vanto una forma di vanto No io sono un
gran lavoratore e uno degli dei
complimenti più belli più forti più
sentiti per un italiano ad un certo
punto ti si ritorce contro arrivi al
punto in cui ti rivolgi un coach per
dire il mio problema non sono ottenere
risultati Io questi li ottengo da sempre
il mio problema è che i miei figli Stan
crescendo da soli e che mia moglie mi ha
dato lautaut è che io non so fare altro
in nessun altro modo
lì diventa importante capire cominciare
a mettere in discussione delle proprie
convinzioni soprattutto se non sono più
funzionali per noi
Allora prima il dovere puoi il piacere
se ci pensate io me lo sono raffigurato
e notate anche la qualità delle slide me
lo sono raffigurato in questo modo
ci hanno sempre insegnato che se tu fai
il tuo dovere prima o poi il piacere ce
l'avrà se tu fai il tuo dovere prima o
poi il premio finale tu ce l'avrai
Allora se pensa un'immagine penso al
cavallo che corre facendo la cosa che
gli riesce meglio facendo la cosa per la
quale è nato e si impegna e corre sempre
più forte per arrivare
a raggiungere quel piacere il premio
finale la carota perché non si accorge
che quella carota è semplicemente un
bastone collegato a una alla carota è
collegata a un bastone attaccata alla
schiena
e lui non sa che sì ce l'ha lì davanti
ma difficilmente la raggiungerà e sapete
perché Perché quando tu fai un
comportamento per un sufficiente lasso
di tempo questo comportamento diventa
un'abitudine è un'abitudine non è altro
che un comportamento talmente ripetuto
diventare automatico
arrivo un momento in cui
Tu corri
convinto che ci sarà il premio finale ma
sti sei talmente abituato a correre che
il premio finale cioè il piacere diventa
un e poi
e nella tua testa c'è prima il dovere
c'è solamente prima il dovere
esattamente come per Diego razionalmente
lui sa
che dovrebbe fermarsi È solo che non
riesce a farlo sapete perché non
riusciva a farlo sapete perché
perché si è abituato per 20 anni per 25
anni
a fare il suo dovere che sembra una cosa
assurda no sembra un paradosso
Allora l'ho sfidato esattamente come
chiedo a voi una sfida perché è facile
venire qui No ha detto bene Lisa
all'inizio questo il tema di questo
tedex si chiama prospettive e le
prospettive Che cos'è cambiare
prospettiva
accettare il cambiamento significa
mettere in discussione qualche cosa che
magari con cui magari hai convissuto per
anni ed è facile quando metti in
discussione qualche cosa che non dai per
scontato
ma avere coraggio significa tante volte
andare a guardare andare a avere il
coraggio di mettere dubbio a qualche
cosa con il quale magari siamo cresciuti
un po' più difficile così
è un po' più difficile così e io mi
ricordo che Diego dissi questa frase
Facciamo una cosa
ribaltiamo il proverbio Cosa
succederebbe se partissimo dal piacere
Cosa succederebbe se il piacere se tu
cominciassi a dedicarti al piacere e poi
al tuo dovere mi ha guardato Come vedo
la maggior parte di voi mi sta guardando
in questo momento
e non capiva e faccio attenzione ti do
un dettaglio in più
tu hai sempre considerato il piacere
come il premio finale
dopo che hai compiuto il tuo dovere per
tu sei tra quelle persone e
probabilmente Qui ce ne sono diverse che
in realtà amano tantissimo quello che
fanno per Diego
iniziare alle 7 del mattino a lavorare e
finire le 7:30 di sera non era un dovere
non era uno sforzo stava si stava
dedicando a qualcosa che aveva creato
con le sue mani
diventava un dovere che cosa la
frustrazione del fatto che a causa delle
abitudini che aveva
creato non riusciva a dedicarsi a
qualcosa che gli dava benzina che gli
dava carburante non aveva più tempo per
lui non aveva più tempo per la sua
attività fisica non aveva più tempo per
i figli Tanto è vero che la sua
lamentela era crescono senza di me
arrivava a casa la sera con E durante il
giorno abbiamo degli ottimi propositi
questa sera gioca con i miei bambini
questa sera porto mia moglie fuori
questo weekend andiamo al mare Andiamo
in montagna arrivavo il weekend il
sabato mattina però aveva questo impegno
urgente al lavoro
il sabato pomeriggio staccava un attimo
e poi si addormentava sul divano
e la volontà gli diceva non farlo per un
po' resistito e poi l'abitudine
Ovviamente devi recuperare il tuo corpo
ti porta a dover recuperare Io ricordo
che gli disse da una cosa e l'invito che
faccio a voi
se condissi se considerassimo il piacere
non come il premio finale ma come il
carburante partire dal piacere non
significa partire dal premio finale non
ci sono premi da vincere
c'è un carburante c'è l'energia c'è il
carburante che ti permette di nutrire le
tue emozioni c'è il carburante che ti
permette di nutrire la tua pancia c'è il
carburante che ti permette di dedicarti
a quei piccoli rituali che ti consentono
di dedicarti meglio al tuo dovere
e il lavoro che ho fatto lungo lui è
stato questo creare dei rituali rituali
sono comportamenti
rituali sono abitudini ma c'è una
piccola differenza la domanda che
era questa cosa accadrebbe Se partissimo
da ciò che più in linea con noi invece
di partire da ciò che qualcuno ha detto
che dovrebbe fare è un bel cambio di
prospettiva Se ci pensate e il coraggio
di farsi delle domande diverse
porta pensieri diversi e quando tu hai
pensieri diversi
hai naturalmente stati d'animo diversi e
questo ti consente di fare azioni
diverse
da lì abbiamo creato come vi dicevo dei
rituali Prima abbiamo parlato di
abitudini Adesso vi sto parlando di
rituali rituali non significa secondi
lavori No no I rituali sono quelle
piccole cose piccole abitudini piccoli
comportamenti che ti nutrono che ti
permettono di non andare mai in riserva
e quando non vai mai in riserva hai
l'energia il focus per dedicarti al tuo
dovere senza sentirti in colpa
In pratica I rituali sono abitudini con
dentro un'anima
e vi lascio con una domanda visto che
sono le domande che creano nuove
prospettive se il risultato finale è
così importante perché è finale
Grazie
[Applauso]